[Music]
hello chaps you caught me in quite a
pickle you see I was looking for a fancy
dress outfit but it seems the world's
gone PC mad I'd be accused of taking but
did you redo if I was seen out with
inmates in this getup those nothing
better to do trouble knocking
campaigners would say I'm guilty of
cultural appropriation of the highest
order but here's a real puzzler when
Prince William was in Pakistan recently
he took every opportunity to Dona
Shivani or put a chit rowley
on his head much in the same way
countless politicians and some other
Royals have done down the years all over
the world but that's seen as a gesture
of kinship we don't expect Imran Khan's
address like Jacob reason bog if he
comes the number-10 nor would an african
chief be expected to wear a bowler hat
and carry a rolled-up umbrella so can
anyone explain what is appropriate when
it comes to cultural appropriation okay
that was quite funny and congratulations
on the accent that's all but but this is
quite a serious issue it's not one that
bugs me a lot because we have a very
weird conception of the concept of
cultural appropriation absolutely
because cultures should mix pretending
that culture shouldn't mix is inherently
racist it's it's it's basically bigoted
it's saying this is my culture right
imagine if somebody from Western from
Western culture said it's cultural
appropriation of somebody for mechanical
culture that doesn't traditionally wear
suits to wear a suit it is inherently
bigoted to suggest the culture shouldn't
mix however if you mix a culture if you
adopt a culture or an element of that
culture but still continue to
discriminate against people from that
culture for example a
you wear dreadlocks but hesitate about
hiring Jamaicans or if you are well if
you do it in a disrespectful way for
example if you put on what black bass is
an example doing it things I mean that
is overtly offensive and taking the mick
then that goes into say into the
category of well this is offensive that
is what I would call culture
appropriation but mixing of cultures
that is a good thing so in a sentence
William or politicians or Harry when
they wear this or they wear cowboy hats
or they wear whatever they wear
absolutely good as long as it's done
respectfully Greg I went once with her
on a trip to China with a bunch of media
guys mainly from America and we all went
and we'd all had it was instructed to
have the appropriate Chinese jacket
shirt the rest it after about a week we
hadn't worn them at all and we decided
collectively we were all going to wear
them to this one dinner so we all the
white because everybody was white white
Americans and Brits and Europeans turned
up in cook and all the Chinese turned up
in Black Tie and it was we said that we
were rolling around laughing and sang
but it was but nothing was done as
disrespect so let's just take a look at
William and Kate and I should warn them
some flash photography I think they look
great and and they were seen as
respecting the culture it's not correct
they do look amazing but again Imran
Khan does not wear a three-piece suit
when he comes and Diana and we went to
the Middle East essentially Muslim
countries and and we were the women the
Western women were given a list of what
we couldn't couldn't wear you can wear
anything the expose your knees and if
you look Kate never does
you couldn't expose your elbows and
there were certain ways you have to sit
so I think what they have done they have
done what they've done out of absolute
respect but I think what you're saying
about the other thing and family saying
or - you know it's outrageous that for
anyone to stay we should stay in the
cultural lane to which we were born into
I mean if it was me I'm after Geordie
off Scottish so that leaves me with
Tavish anta's and study cakes it's not a
good it's not a good way to go but it's
if you live in a multicultural society
cultural appropriation is inevitable the
exchange of styles food clothes whatever
it isn't and to me it's a very positive
thing what it's saying is I really like
this
I want to emulate a chair whatever and
it's not insulting anyone if any quick
one then I'll bring any Machaut you I
can hear you I'm just reminds me of a
joke by Rowan Atkinson he said them I
like curry but but but now we've got the
recipe is there really any need for them
to stay now that is the idea of culture
appropriation you're benefiting from the
culture but you're still discriminating
against people who you might have
complimented me on my accent I can't do
the same thing I'm really sorry
well I've got an interesting set
actually from across the pond and if
people were asked in America is 36% of
Americans apparently aged 18 to 24 years
old say that they hold back from trying
new things for fear of committing
cultural appropriation and that actually
makes me sad and it also makes me
cautious of what I would call the overly
/ easily offended brigade because when
somebody's wearing something so if I
think of an outfit or a garment or
whatever that is traditionally
associated with a group of people or
culture does that mean that they have
ownership of and I would argue that no
it does not so if you have a Garmin or a
hairstyle or whatever it is if you're
doing it simply to take the mick that's
one thing for example no one would
reasonably think that you wore
dreadlocks because you genuinely thought
that would be a good look for you but if
you were so if you were to wear
dreadlocks one would assume you were
doing a simple two takes all right I
can't for the life of me see why I'd be
denigrating a black woman by putting
corners in my hair I would be doing it
because I like them and I would maybe
think I would look okay with them but
but a lot of people get it again it
depends on your general attitude towards
the people from whom the culture
originated so as long as you are
somebody who is respectful people from
that culture that's absolutely fine show
in ministry as much as I you know never
thought I'd hear myself do this I'm
thinking of a love island contestant and
she wore her hair in cornrows actually
went on Instagram and she's a a white
British girl she had a hair in commerce
she was absolutely lambasted if you want
to have your hair in plat and I
frequently do by the way I often have
cornrows in my hair if I want to do my
hair like that I bloody well will I'm
not being offensive the people that seem
to be getting offended on behalf of
other people that are not even offended
for themselves and is that which
frustrates me one of my very best
friends white British girl she married a
Hindu man and for the wedding she had
two weddings one in a like a British
style wedding of one as a Hindu ceremony
and we were we consulted with the Hindu
guests to help we asked for their help
to help us choose a traditional Hindu
outfit to make sure you know was covered
up in the right places and we dress the
same as the other Hindu guess because we
wanted to and what's wrong with that
because it's lovely and complimentary
and you're not you're actually saying I
love this it's about respect yeah that's
about respect absolutely and there are
ways in which you can share a culture
that show rip they show respect and
there are ways in which you can adopt a
culture they show disrespect the people
are that culture describing [ __ ] was not
showing disrespect okay up after the
break I'm going out with a bang
[Music]